[Music]
in questionable policies news submitted
by Oreos are vegan online personality
and comedian steven crowder refuses to
be silenced after upsetting everyone
with homophobic comments so i don't know
if you guys heard this one this one this
is kind of like a controversy that's
happened over the past couple weeks but
steven crowder he's an online he's a
youtube conservative comedian who does
what he calls a late-night show so like
I think he runs live streams at certain
times and he he tries to comedic ly
attack the left and so he got in trouble
because he can I don't he does these
videos where he tries to debunk certain
topics and certain people who he feels
are attacking conservative ideology and
so he went after a Vox employee by the
name of Carlos masa and he basically
Carlos Mazda likes to refer to himself
constantly as a gay Latino and so steven
crowder repeatedly calls him a gay
latino to make fun of that or so steven
crowder says and there's a video that
was released on twitter that has like a
supercut of like steven crowder just
being like it's saint queer like 20,000
times exactly he's like mexican queer
gay mexican all this stuff and it sounds
like a pejorative yeah which is a bad
thing so a lot of the Crowder defenders
feel like it was taken out of context
because the context of his jokes was to
make fun of that he has to proclaim who
he is as he says things so he would have
made that joke if i said as the king of
england that's that's what there's
that's the he was making an emphasis on
why do you have to title yourself every
time you say something right and then
there's even a quote in there where he
says like you wouldn't even have a job
if you weren't a gay person but i guess
in his reports or like whatever videos
he was making for vox like was that
relevant to bring up that he was a gay
mexico so when crowder rebuttals things
like he takes the video of whoever is
talking and and maza did a lot of video
for Vox and he like let's the video play
and then he does what like a rebuttal
what would he calls a rebuttal to what
maza says so in his rebuttal he's he
feels like he's making fun of the fact
that he has to say all that stuff so
it's like as a game Mexican boy you're
gay Mexican aren't you you look talking
about how you're a gay Mexican so you're
a gay Mexican and you as you prance to
cross the stage or whatever the [ __ ] I
see so even if it is relevant for him to
mention he is a gay Mexican to Crowder
is just like that's funny you even said
it period that's funny that you kept
saying that's the joke I think that's
taken out of context he says and that's
what his defenders because I watched it
and it makes sense like how that joke
was constructed but then I also watched
the snippets and if you add all of those
small segments together it looks really
mean well it's not that I mean there's a
so so I understand now the gay latino
whatever but then there were all the
other snippets where it's like oh here's
a lesbian with the lesbian haircut or
whatever and it's like well what how was
how's that taking on a context to me
life thing and there's a very dark sense
of humor that's why you're here with us
mad I do this is sticky it's a good idea
I really like put together it sounds I
was hustle I also watched a couple of
clips of his like entire thing yeah
and it didn't seem as bad or you see it
like this especially as Carlos yes I
would obviously be bothered or hurt to
see it just I think there's there's more
baggage and weight to his words because
he comes from conservative background so
like when he's saying it the way he does
it just seems like like he got
personally attacked and he's really just
trying to like cut him true but it only
seems that way if you watch the
compilation sure you cheat you yeah it
makes a lot more sense
I actually watched the original Fox
video and it was called why I forgot but
that was the one that that the original
one that steven crowder was breaking
down and then that's where it all kind
of started and in box posted a video and
then Steven
rebuttal to that video and then the the
the this animation
yeah the compilations came out and then
Steven Crowder's channel got demonetised
yes so that's that's what is going on it
was almost like he was put on not even
put on trial he was just guilty guilty
Carlos was cause lobbied to have steven
crowder demonic yes I don't even think
he would question I didn't YouTube just
sided with Carlos without even looking
into it just real quick to work to
contextualize this this is what Carlos -
can you read this oh yeah I saw this one
yeah yeah oh you want me to read it oh
yeah so I have pretty thick skin when it
comes to online harassment but something
has been really bothering me since I
started working at Vox steven crowder
has been making video after video
debunking strikethrough every single
video has included repeated over attacks
on my sexual orientation and ethnicity
here's a sample :
bring this down or up - down I get it
guys it's amateur hour okay alright so
so here's here's what YouTube says in
response to that may you thanks again
one out of four thanks again for taking
the time to share all of this
information with us we take allegations
of harassment very seriously we know
this is important and impacts a lot of
people and so so then YouTube also says
our team's spent the last few days
conducting an in-depth review of the
videos blacks to us and while we found
language that was clearly hurtful the
videos as posted don't violate our
policies we've included more info below
to explain this decision and then they
said as an open platform it's crucial
for us to allow everyone from creators
to journalists to late-night TV hosts to
express their opinions within the scope
of our policies opinions can be deeply
offensive but if they don't violate our
policies they'll remain on our site and
then they continue even if a video
remains on our site it doesn't mean we
endorse or support that viewpoint there
are other aspects of the channel that
we're still evaluating we'll be in touch
with any further update so how did he
get demonetised so that okay so that was
before then you
to came out and basically said we
suspended this channels monetization
that was the next step because they got
dragged down hard to got like just pull
through the mud for not I think people
want to be this channel done weeded yeah
first of all they did all day decided
that these people who were attacking
don't like steven crowder and they're
like let's [ __ ] i don't want him to
be able to speak on this platform
anymore it seemed like youtube was cool
with it was of was for freedom of
opinion like we should be able to voice
your opinions on it's not offensive it
violates their their usage and all of
sudden they just demonetised
use who's been in a lot of like hot
water with like LGBT issues and like de
monetizing gay creators and gay topics
and stuff like that so i feel like this
particular thread that carlos made
really just gained traction and almost
kind of pushed them up against the wall
like oh you've been doing this business
to get creators and now you have this
compilation that you're going to ignore
that a lot of people considered hate
speech
gangs see when a platform has to take a
political position or a moral position i
think that's when things get [ __ ] up
it's scary yeah and and then also carlos
monza came out and said de monetizing
doesn't work he's like abusers use it as
proof they're being discriminated
against and they make millions off
selling merch doing speaking gays and
getting their followers to support them
on patreon the ad revenue isn't the
problem it's the platform basically
saying like shut him out don't just de
monetize him
I want this guy gone basically and
that's that's where a lot of people are
like this is this is I don't know if
this is a bridge too far for me I don't
know I mean there's a lot of I think
annoying videos that steven crowder has
but he also has some that are like oh
man I'm glad that they were brave enough
to have this discussion to change my
mind stuff
yeah because they have they had one
after this whole thing they had one
where he's in front of the Google office
at Austin talking about this exact issue
and he had a lawyer and all that and I
was like man that makes a lot of sense
you know just because one group feels
that what you're saying is hateful and
mean that they get the power to
completely shut you up now that can be
our channel do we see a lot of [ __ ] that
pisses people off from a community you
point it
it's outer sometimes it's taken out of
contact all the time but then if enough
people are pissed about it like they can
shut us down
wait then what the [ __ ] is the point of
freedom of speech I don't get it but if
a lot of people are upset at it doesn't
it mean that it's bright doesn't it mean
that that's a mob mentality like you're
letting the mob decide for Pete for
everyone so you're saying that the
masses yeah but we're supposed to do as
if you're a platform we're supposed to
remain neutral but then YouTube jumped
on the mob side but if the masses is
saying hey like we keep getting sad and
upset and hurt over this you're supposed
to be molasses getting it was one person
getting upset who happens to have
somewhat of attraction of a fanbase now
because of a thread so my question is
like in the gay community were they all
binding behind Carlos behind like
backing them up and saying yo this is I
saw some people doing it and I remember
sending the thread and articles about
YouTube ignoring it and a group chat and
it was like very it's different because
not everyone cares the same mm like I
busted out laughing we watched okay so
when he said the thing about the lesbian
because that's true that's how I am with
Asian videos yeah but see I'm someone
that I love comedy like I guess certain
things and some people are not like that
and it's like who do you they don't get
it could they're idiots and then what
ends up happening is they look at you
and be like how come you're not standing
with your chin now why aren't we a
monolith no we all agree on literally
everything yeah but that's the thing
like I wouldn't come out and be like
Carlos is a mess
I think Carlos's feelings are valid but
it doesn't bother me but again I'm not
him yeah so you feel like getting the
Crowder's channel getting demonetized is
a little too far
a little cheap I mean I don't know his
whole history but based on these clips
no like yeah and he's like threatening
his life what if something else happened
that we don't know about like I just see
him taking the piss out of Carlos's own
like labeling so Carlos also has said
that he was doxxed and not by crowds
direction because Crowder has I saw a
compilation of crowded like denouncing
daxing and [ __ ] but um let's Doxie
Daxing is when they find
where you live what your phone number is
your email all that [ __ ] yeah and they
were spamming Carlos Moses text because
we and if you say that because they were
spamming his text saying debate steven
crowder debates to me forever like a
bunch of times and Carlos felt unsafe
and all that kind of stuff I see that so
does that waist point Steven should
speak out it would be like don't do that
and he asked okay so so so but that's
the argument that Carlos made is like I
have been directly affected by what he
feels as a bullying campaign and
Crowder's like you put content on
YouTube and I have been debunking the
content that you make isn't that allowed
so that's where both sides stand mmm
damn it's tough man like when you have
crazy fan bases and how can you like if
you have like a crazy fan who does
something for you but they don't know it
like [ __ ] a guy who loved Jodie
Foster thought if I shoot Ronald Reagan
she'll love me like he wrote that really
happened that's why Ronald Reagan got
got shot but it's not his fault not
that's not his fault easy people are
gonna do what crazy people gonna do it's
not Jodie Foster's bad because Jodie
Foster didn't [ __ ] single is gonna do
it she had a crazy fan who did something
that he thought was for her cuz he's
crazy yeah if you're out there saying
like kill this group then it makes sense
that it's your fault because and then
that would be violating the policy so
the fact that you didn't violate the
policies I don't think you should've
gone to Montana right so there's a
subreddit on YouTube called the Donald
that just got quarantined by reddit
because reddit claims that they used
violent they were advocating for
violence against police officers in
Oregon who were summoned to take a bunch
of Republican lawmakers and put them
back in the Capitol for a vote on a
climate change bill and a couple people
in the comments of the Donald which is a
huge subreddit that has tens of
thousands opposed today they said like
if if that was me if they came for me
that's why I have a rifle and you know
they can this is why I have this we have
the Second Amendment and stuff like that
so you to read it use that as an excuse
to quarantine the Donald
because they say that that's advocating
violence but if you go on Reddit and you
look at other sub reddits we're like
there's a subreddit about that's anti
cops and stuff and they have in there
like stuff that's like I'd kill that cop
I'm glad that cop died and nobody cares
so it's one of those things where
conservatives feel targeted by this they
feel like the rules only apply to them
and not to the rest of everybody look
said I think there's difference between
targeting a group of people and making
fun of one specific person and I think
context is important and when you like
blur the tool or get like your fans to
feel some type of way because something
happened to you is where I think things
get tricky and kind of like just muddy
and kind of confuses everyone mm-hmm
because it takes away from actual like
discrimination and hatred and it becomes
a thing of like are they just talking
about me yes I never heard him say
anything about gay people where the gay
communities just talking about that guy
hurt yeah I heard him talking to Carlos
same with me so I don't know maybe
people might be just seeing him doing
the act outs of like the gay act out and
stuff and they might get hurt because
they've been bullied like that before
mm-hmm even though it's not about them
right so the people just see other
things when you know and they make sense
of it on their in their own way so I
think that's that's what ends up
happening is when people can't really
understand what's going on and they see
snippets of something they draw their
own conclusion and get mad or support or
whatever and I'm like just leave it
alone the scary part is that his channel
could just get demonetized without like
a proper trial or something that is this
people that actually look at this hate
speech is he violating the usage and
then they just take his money away
that's pretty nuts and they're pretty
they've told him before he was banned
they said you've fallen in terms of
service you're okay because they had had
personal meetings in person to make sure
that everything was chill and then they
date after the pressure this last bit of
huge amount of pressure they just said
he's demonetised don't worry about I get
off her back you know what's even
crazier is
they can't even define what hate
speeches I'm noticed that's the crazy
part because then it's subjective to
whoever's controlling like on the filter
so like yeah like let's say we get
reported right and then let's say the
person behind the screen is like a 19
year old and and they're like they
determine if your channel is violating
hate speech or not right yes they're
being overworked to remember we did a JK
news episode on the people that are in
charge of looking at whatever is being
flagged like they're being so overworked
that they're like delusional sometimes
because they don't sleep they don't get
paid enough so that whole system is
broken yeah exactly and what if they
don't understand the comedy so they
don't understand the context and they're
taking it literally so damn there's a
lot of dangers to it
[Music]